[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كل الامطار اللي تنزل علينا له مصدرين
مصدر عالمي ومصدر محلي العالمي يجينا من
هضبه البحيرات من وسط افريقيا او من بحر
العرب واهمها الافريقي ليش لان يتزامن
قدومه الينا مع دخول موسم الوسم في شهر
سبتمبر واغزرها هو الذي يتقدم الينا من
بحر العرب ليش لانه ياتينا في اخر الصيف
متزامنا مع دخول موسم سهيل وهلنا الاولين
الله يرحمهم يقولون لا دخل سهيل لا تامن
السيل والمحليه اما تخريجات من بحر العرب
وعاده ما تكون غزيره لكنها تكون في بقعه
دون ثانيه مثل ما حصل على جده ومكه او من
بقاع من الحرات وتقوم تطبخ السحاب
والرطوبه وتتحول الى سحب ناطره عموما كلا
الامطار اللي نزلت علينا من اول الوسم الى
هذه الايام هي امطار محليه الصنع
سمننا بدقيقه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]